the Joe Rogan experience these rubber
bullets that these cops are unique in
code testers how [ __ ] up is this that
they're just shooting them into people
get directly yeah they're supposed to
hit him off the ground
they're shooting them at [ __ ]
reporters you see those reporters
reporters yeah interviewing these people
and like wow wow what the [ __ ] yes he's
getting shot at I know my cops that know
their reporters yes I know and a
reporter lost her eye recently my ABC
reporter someone like that yeah guy hit
me high with a rubber bullet just
recently like yesterday or so oh my god
and lost an eye that happened to when I
was at the WTO riots you know like one
second you're like oh cool the chief of
police is talking to the lead organizer
and he's got his helmet off and
everyone's like oh this is cool they're
all talking and then from behind the
police lines you hear a bullhorn we're
gonna be launching teargas please clear
the area and you're like wait a minute
but you guys were just talking it's like
I don't know and then he doesn't know
because there was another order placed
by someone that wasn't him and then
suddenly turns into pandemonium and the
next thing you know another dude loses
him like guy that I knew that was a
friend of a friend lost his eye and the
WTO rights because the guy the the
police officer shot at him directly
instead of bouncing it off the ground
it's just like and it comes down to my
gun my gun guru dude that I was you know
training with for for a film and that's
kind of what launched me back into into
stuff but he was saying training
training training like when it comes to
police officers it's community outrage
reach being able to actually establish a
contact with your community so that you
they can at least have some form of
trust or someone that they can talk to
that they can relate to so they
understand the police are there for the
protection then the other thing is like
training a lot of these officers are
just like they're just sending them out
and going hey good luck deal with stuff
as it happens and then some of the cats
are like they don't know and they their
anger gets the best of them someone's
being indignant and they're like you
know what I'm gonna lay it down
I just think most people do not have the
kind of temperament and character to
deal with being in a position of having
control over other people really
ultimate fatal control over other people
I just don't think they have that I
think most people I mean
think that takes a really powerful
person and there are powerful people out
there that handle it handle it well and
they're great cops yes and then there's
guys like that guy who put his [ __ ]
knee on that man's neck for eight
minutes and 38 seconds over whatever was
and finally the the family got their own
autopsy and the the autopsy showed the
man did die from yeah not not just his
fixation but also from the blood being
cut off to the brain jeez
which is really what it is it's a blood
choke because you're you're putting your
shin on the side of the neck it's
cutting off the carotid artery it's like
a choke like like a jujitsu choke you
know the idea that that's not what
killed him is like come on what was just
a coincidence I mean what is the autopsy
like how corrupt er your [ __ ] metal
medical examiner's man I'm telling you
it's yeah I know where they're like
whole we need to get we need to get
ahead of this it's like you know just
probably just like he had pre-existing
conditions yeah yeah it's called being
black yes well being God being arrested
especially by that guy that guy had 12
different abuse forms that were yeah
abuse claims against him over the years
yeah I know and and the guys that were
just kind of sitting there you know the
cops that were sitting there it's like
they yeah again it's also a training
issue it's like you know and if you're a
cop and you you you've noticed another a
fellow officer in the field doing some
[ __ ] that they think is like not cool or
just straight illegal whatever or
they're you have a feeling that it's
gonna escalate with this person if
they're if it's left unchecked they
really it's hard for them to communicate
to you because there's this whole
Brotherhood loyalty hang that locks
everybody into like this code of silence
and it sucks because well how do you
expect police departments to get better
if police departments aren't allowing
themselves to get better well some some
people that do step out they get in
trouble right yeah if some people that
do call out other officers for shitty
behavior but there was one woman really
recently I think it was either yesterday
or today there was a guy and he's
arguing with these protesters this male
cop and this woman gets on her knees in
front of him and says she's on her knee
and he shoves her to the ground when
when she's on her knees and this female
officer gets in the guy's face and
starts yelling at him and and he's as
he's walking away she's chasing him down
and yelling at him oh and it's all on
video
so there are example yes of good cops
who see cops being abusive yeah hey find
this guy was clearly abusive like
there's one guy standing there and he
got right in the guy's face like
intimidating them and then and then
pushed the girl down look there's a lot
of people that shouldn't beat cops and
then the stress of those situations
where you trying to try and take control
of a mob ya know it could do it turns
back or you get that sheriff from Flint
Michigan did you see that video that was
a maze that was amazing a fool brings a
tear to your eye really dude he's like
we're gonna put down the batons we're
gonna march with you yes we're all
together in this yes and you know and we
want you to have a voice yeah and then
he's hugging people and everybody's
hugging everybody yeah and they're
walking together so imagine the cop that
pushed the lady down and put him in that
situation with those people yeah that
same aggro attitude he'd be yelling to
people and tell him to shut the [ __ ] up
and pushed him away and it probably
would have escalated or imagine that cop
with in the other scenario with that
woman on the ground he'd probably be
like ma'am I don't want you on your
knees we're all in this together like we
all saw what happened to that man that's
an injustice yeah let's walk together
let's let's try to heal this community
would you try let's try to do better
yeah that's what I want to see man I
mean that's all I that's all it comes
down to it's a a you know I it's all
about behavior how you handle a
situation in the moment and again if
they had a little bit of training yeah a
little bit of training to say like stop
before think stop think then assess the
situation and you know unless your life
is in danger like you know but that
these situations are not that these are
cops that are like something happens
there's like something clicks and
there's chaos all around and the
instinct is like essentially the same
mentality as someone who's taking
advantage of it on the other side you
were like that people who come out after
the initial rage wave of like ah you
know which is a natural kind of
biological instinct and it's a rebound
singing but then there the opportunists
that sneak in behind the wave and those
are the people that you see like
targeting in a very organized way
targeting these stores knowing exactly
where they're gonna go and they're gonna
take advantage of these moments of chaos
yeah so of course that gets mixed in and
the cops see that and it's like well
they kind of get on get in on that
wavelength instead of the majority
wavelength which is just like we're
pissed we're emotional we're loud but
we're allowed to do this
[Applause]